c'est un véritable réquisitoire contre
l'armée malienne celle-ci est accusée
d'avoir perpétré un massacre au centre
du Mali Amoura village de près de 7000
habitants au moins 500 personnes ont été
tuées entre le 27 et le 31 mars 2022
selon l'ONU à cette époque l'armée
malienne lance une opération
antiterroriste dans une zone fortement
dominée par des groupes djihadistes
affiliés à Al-Qaïda mais l'opération
tourne au carnage une enquête du
Haut-Commissariat des Nations Unies au
droit de l'homme publiait le 12 mai mais
clairement en cause les forces maliennes
il s'agit d'une vingtaine de civils tués
le 27 mars par des tirs aériens
effectués par les forces armées
maliennes et les personnels militaires
étrangers pour empêcher la population de
s'enfuir et de quitter Moura et d'au
moins 500 individus y compris une
vingtaine de femmes et 7 enfants
exécutés par les forces armées maliennes
et les personnels militaires étrangers
entre le 27 et le 31 mars après que la
zone a été totalement maîtrisée dans cet
extrait l'expression personnelle
militaire étrangère désigne en réalité
les mercenaires russes de Wagner dont le
rapport rappelle les liens avec la jinte
militaire au pouvoir au Mali le rapport
décrit aussi le déroulement des faits le
27 mars vers 11h05 hélicoptères arrivent
à Moura le jour de la foire la plus
importante dans cette région
un cinquième hélicoptère resté en survol
au-dessus du village aurait ouvert le
feu de manière indiscriminée en
direction du carbal lieu où se tenait la
foire hebdomadaire entraînant un
mouvement de foule vers le centre du
village les militaires débarquaient
auraient également de manière
indiscriminée tirés sur les personnes
qui essaient de s'enfuir dans les heures
suivantes les forces armées maliennes et
ce que les témoignages qualifient Dom
armés blancs auraient interpellé au
moins 3000 personnes tous des hommes
tout âge confondus avant de les répartir
en plusieurs groupes les hommes armés
blancs faisaient le tri pour déterminer
qui était considéré comme djihadiste
avant d'orienter les victimes vers la
direction ou les forces armées maliennes
les exécutaient
s'exprimant dans une langue jamais
entendue auparavant selon les mots de
témoins ces soldats blancs trier les
hommes d'une certaine façon des
caractéristiques physiques comme le fait
de porter la barbe de porter un pantalon
court au-dessus de la cheville ou
d'avoir des marques sur l'épaule
avant de partir malien et russe ont
imposé aux habitants d'enterrer les
corps dans des fosses communes visibles
sur cette image satellite et selon les
informations de l'enquête de l'ONU l'ONU
ajoute qu'elle a des motifs raisonnables
de croire que 58 femmes et jeunes filles
ont été victimes de viol et autres
formes de violences sexuelles durant
l'opération dans un cash choquant des
soldats auraient apportés des couchettes
d'une maison les oreilles placées sous
des arbres dans le jardin puis au raurez
violé à tour de rôle les femmes qu'ils
avaient forcé à s'y installer c'est fait
était déjà connu par les récits de
médias et d'OMG comme human right Swatch
ou Amnesty internationale mais ce
rapport de l'ONU les rend officiel et
ouvre donc des conséquences judiciaires
car ces actes peuvent constituer des
crimes contre l'humanité la gente
malienne a d'ailleurs tout fait pour
bloquer la diffusion du rapport et
c'était appuyé sur le veto de la Russie
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU en avril
2022 pour empêcher une enquête
indépendante Bamako a dénoncé un rapport
biaisé reposant sur un récit fictif
ainsi que l'utilisation des satellites
au-dessus de mourra pour obtenir des
images les Etats-Unis de leur côté se
sont dit atterrés par les exactions
commises par l'armée malienne pour
rappel la France est retirée
militairement du Mali en août 2022 après
des tensions avec la jinte Malienne et
le développement d'un fort sentiment
anti-français entretenu par la
propagande russe
[Musique]